The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ELIZABETH CHOE: All right, so
everyone is here for 20.219,
correct, Becoming
the Next Bill Nye?
No one's in the wrong room?
All right.
OK, well, welcome to the class.
I'm Elizabeth, I run
the K12 videos program.
Maybe we can do a quick intro
with the staff over here.
So Jamie, you want to--
JAIME GOLDSTEIN: Hi,
I'm Jaime Goldstein.
I run the communication lab
in Biological Engineering,
and I oversee it in Nuclear
Science and Engineering
as well.
CERI RILEY: I'm Ceri.
I am the TA for this class.
I'm a junior in Comparative
Media Studies and Biology.
JOSH GUNN: I'm Josh.
I run an animation
studio here in Cambridge
called Planet Nutshell.
CHRIS BOEBEL: I'm Chris Boebel.
I'm Media Development
Director at MITx,
and I also teach a
class here at MIT
called DV Lab on
documentary, and I'll
be guest lecturing for
a couple of sessions.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Come
on in, take a seat.
So just logistics stuff.
All the information
about this class
is on our Tumblr, which I'll
email it out to you guys,
but it's mit219.tumblr.com.
And you'll find the class
syllabus, all the links,
all the videos that I'll be
showing you during class,
and basically
everything you need
to know about just
homework assignments
and things like that.
So we're just going to go
ahead and dive right in.
This class is about writing,
hosting, and producing video,
short-form video, but in the
context of this sort of scary,
amorphous blob that people
talk about a lot, the problems
in science, technology, and
engineering and math education.
And the specific
problems that we're
going to be trying
to be thinking
about in the context
of making these videos
are these three
problems, which is
that the culture that we
have right now, especially
with video and science,
is that it kind of implies
that the door to
science and engineering,
whether or not you
want to be a scientist
or whether or not
you want to study it,
is only open to certain people.
We also have this
issue of maintaining
a love of lifelong learning.
Josh I were just talking
about the dark ages, when
you quit playing with LEGOs.
But kids are very
curious creatures,
and somehow our
educational system
squelches that curiosity.
And science and engineering
are these topics
that I'm sure you guys
are very excited about.
I'm very excited about it too.
But somehow it becomes this
sort of boring subject,
and especially in high school,
people think of chemistry
as their least favorite class.
It was my least favorite
class in high school.
And then you have this
civic responsibility
as scientists and
engineers to make sure
that you're promoting STEM
literacy among the public.
We don't want everyone
in our culture
to become a scientist
or an engineer.
That would be terrible,
it would be super boring.
It wouldn't really be
helping our society at all.
But at the same time,
science and engineering
affects your daily life.
Whether or not you're an
artist or you're an author,
you're voting on issues that
require a certain knowledge
of science and engineering.
And as scientists
and engineers, we
need to be making
sure that we're
promoting a basic
level of literacy
among the voting public.
So it's a practical
thing for us,
as scientists and engineers.
It's also sharing that
excitement and love
of learning with other
people that maybe they
lost in a boring class
or something like that.
So the idea of this class
is to bring together
the best practices in education,
and some of these problems
that I'm talking about
with STEM education,
and bringing it together
with some of the tools
that we have in entertainment.
So how can we use video, how
can we leverage video to address
that big, amorphous blob.
So we're going to try to
occupy this middle space.
But the problem is that the best
practices in this middle space
have not really
been established.
Part of that is because
there aren't really experts
in edutainment, necessarily.
It's not a super academic field.
It's also pretty new.
The advent of science
entertainment on the web,
especially now it's exploding,
but it's all very new,
so it's hard to establish
the best practices.
And on top of that, the
best practices in education
and the best practices
in entertainment
don't always align.
A lot of times they
conflict with each other.
So a lot of this class
will be piecing together
what's great about
these two disciplines,
and it'll also be sort
of discovering on our own
what are the pieces that we
want to take and implement
ourselves.
At this point, I wanted you guys
to think about this question,
partially to inform us
and help us help you guys
over the course of this month.
But I wanted to get a
sense of why you all
signed up for this class.
Maybe it was because you needed
six extra units to graduate,
which is totally fine.
And also what you wanted
to get out of this class.
If you're coming into
the class and you
want to learn how
to record video,
we want to know if
that's your objective.
If you came in
because you thought
it sounded interesting
or anything like that,
we want to know, too.
So you guys can think
about it, maybe share.
If you don't want to share
right now, that's totally fine.
But I will mention this
at the end of class,
but every day you're
going to be writing
blog posts and
daily reflections,
so hopefully this is something
that you can incorporate
into your reflection today.
JAIME GOLDSTEIN: Elizabeth,
why don't you start?
Why are you here?
ELIZABETH CHOE: Why am I here?
Well, I'm going to talk about
why I'm here after this,
so I don't want to spoil it.
But Jaime, why are you here?
JAIME GOLDSTEIN: Oh, OK.
Really good question.
I run the communication lab
in Biological Engineering,
and that was it.
I oversee Nuclear
Science as well.
And our goal is really to help
scientists learn to communicate
more effectively.
And that's what I do now.
I mostly train graduate
students to talk
to each other about their
science, and to undergraduates,
about how do you tell people
about what you're doing.
And when Elizabeth approached
me-- she was an MBE originally,
so she knew about our lab.
This was a perfect match for
me personally, this course,
because prior to my
life here I taught
middle school for many years,
among the many other things.
I was a magazine editor
for a little while.
So this to me is a perfect
intersection of things
that I'm passionate about,
because your videos are
targeted, that
you're going to be
making for that middle
school population.
And that's one that
I know very well
and that I care about a lot.
So I'm looking forward
to sharing with you
what I know about the work that
I do now blended with the work
that I used to do.
So I'm excited to tap
into your creativity.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Anyone else
want to share why they're here?
No wrong answers.
PAUL FOLINO: My
name's Paul Folino.
I came here to, kind of
on what you were saying,
just try to be able to
convey technical concepts
in a simple way, so I
can explain to someone,
whether it's one of
my friends or someone
like my niece, what I do.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Awesome.
Anyone else?
You will have to stay
it in your blog, though.
JAIME GOLDSTEIN: I want
to hear from everyone.
JOSH CHEONG: I'll
probably go first.
JAIME GOLDSTEIN: Sure.
ELIZABETH CHOE: And
what's your name?
Sorry.
JOSH CHEONG: My name is Joshua.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Joshua.
JOSH CHEONG: You
can call me Josh.
I come from Singapore.
So we're here on a really short
exchange for about a month.
We come from
Singapore University
of Technology and Design.
It's a university that was
started in collaboration
with MIT.
Well, I came to this class
because we study OCW a lot,
and that's because
we are probably
the first [? special ?]
university and most
of our curriculum
comes from MIT.
And honestly, I feel like
close to 25% of my education
comes from online.
And I'm very
comfortable with it,
but-- my mom is a
chemistry teacher,
and she tells me that
students don't necessarily
like stuff like Khan
Academy, because it
might look too boring for them.
And that's kind of my
curiosity right now,
how do I convey something
that people might not
find really interesting but
very important for them,
and make it very interactive.
ELIZABETH CHOE:
It's Yuliya, right?
YULIYA KLOCHAN: Mm-hm.
So I was very interested in
education in high school,
and I noticed that kids don't
like STEM subjects, generally.
And so I just wanted
to, as a career,
pursue promotion
of STEM subjects.
That's one of the
things I'd like to do.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Yes.
JONATHAN: Hi, I'm Jonathan.
ELIZABETH CHOE:
Did you say John?
Josh?
JONATHAN: Jonathan.
ELIZABETH CHOE: John.
JONATHAN: John is fine, too.
So I noticed there were a number
of videos on YouTube popping
up, a number of
educational videos in range
from exciting to pretty boring.
And I think this is a
very powerful medium
to reach kids who
wouldn't normally be
interested in science, or math.
And exposure, and
how you receive
and where you get
information, usually
tends to tip the scales as
far as who's into something
and who's not.
So I think this is a
really cool project.
And I like to be on the other
side of the camera as well.
ANDREA DESROSIERS: I
guess I'll go next.
My name is Andrea.
I'm a Sloan Fellow here at MIT.
So I'm significantly older
than maybe everybody.
What I've been doing for
the past 10 years of my life
has been working in regulatory,
so doing medical device
submissions to the FDA.
So it's a lot of communicating
highly technical information
to people who aren't
exactly laypeople,
but they're not going to be
as familiar with the topic
as, say, I am.
So that's what I've been doing.
And one of the things that
I'd really like to introduce
is using video as another tool
to convey this information.
NATHAN HERNANDEZ:
Hi, I'm Nathan.
I think why I'm taking this
class is [INAUDIBLE] spread
scientific information, too.
At least for me, I think,
not necessarily people
who adore the science, but
just people so they can
be scientifically literate now.
I don't know.
KENNETH CHEAH: Hi, I'm
Kenneth, from SUTD as well.
Back when I first graduated
from junior college,
I actually went to have
a teaching internship
for a period in
Singapore, and that's
when I realized that most
students in Singapore
do not really like blackboard
or whiteboard teaching.
I realized that a
little-- like halfway
into my first week of
doing the internship,
so that's when I revised
everything that I had prepared,
started creating multimedia
tools and animations.
It's been like two,
three years since then.
But the whole idea of
using multimedia as well
as video tools has
still stuck around.
I still regularly,
when I'm bored
and I don't feel like doing my
homework, I'll go on YouTube
and watch all these
random videos,
because at least I learn
something; not relevant,
but something.
So this has always
been an interest.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Does anyone
have any particular goals
out of this month or something
that you want to get out
of taking this class?
That's OK.
We'll give you
goals, don't worry.
All right, well, I won't
torture you any further.
JOSH GUNN: I'll just
mention that I'm
excited about the class.
I run an animation
studio, as I said,
and we do this work every day.
We're engaged in helping
biotechs and technology
companies and educators
explain very complex things,
and sometimes not-so-complex
things, to very young kids.
But I certainly
don't have the market
cornered on how to do this.
And as you said, this isn't
really an academic field,
and there's no grand
unified theory of how
to do this most effectively.
I think a lot of things
are out there right now,
but I'm just excited
to be engaged
in a conversation about
techniques and strategies
for doing this, because
they'll help me in my own work,
and help me understand the
perspective that you guys have
as well.
So thanks.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Great.
As I said in the beginning,
I run the K12 videos program,
which is a fairly new initiative
out of the Office of Digital
Learning here.
So it's the same
group that oversees
MITx and OpenCourseWare.
I produce a series called
Science Out Loud, which
is essentially trying to mix
education and entertainment,
having students like you
guys be the face of science
and the face of engineering.
And to get people not only
educated and informed, but also
inspired as well.
So I've had an interest
in the intersection
of all that stuff, I guess,
since I took Chris' class.
When I was an undergrad
I took his DV Lab class.
But I think it's a
very fascinating area.
And like Josh said,
it's this market
that I don't think anyone
really has cornered
or really-- no one really has
a good grasp on what the best
way to practice in it is.
So I think it's a really
interesting problem,
especially for people at
MIT to think about, as well.
As some of you guys said,
videos have exploded
in the last decade or so.
These are all science
YouTube channels
that have over a million
subscribers each.
And it's not just video
exploding in a certain area.
You have YouTube entertainment
slash educational shows,
and then you have things that
are very lucrative in our pop
culture.
Cosmos was raking in like
five million viewers a week.
Which isn't a whole
lot compared to some
of the other primetime
network shows,
but thinking about the fact
that a science-based show aired
on the FOX Network
during a primetime slot
and was raking in those
views is pretty amazing.
And then you have movies
like Interstellar,
which are addressing a lot
of real science topics,
and is also making like $50
million during opening weekend.
And then you have things
like edX and OpenCourseWare,
and all these open
education resources that
are video-based, and
are also reaching
this incredible audience
and have a huge group
of people investing in it.
And these are all very, very
different styles of video,
but they're all unified by this
theme that they're using video
and they're accumulating
a huge database of users.
So something must be
happening with video
that's making it
compelling for people
to use to learn
and to entertain.
What can video do?
What is it about
video that makes it
so compelling to use as a tool?
Educationally, you have stuff
like OpenCourseWare that's
really great, because people
can pause the video whenever
they want, they can rewind
and rewatch an explanation.
And it's also super
scalable, so it
means that you don't have to
be physically in Cambridge
to hear Eric Lander talk about
genetics in the 7.012 class.
You can be anywhere
in the world.
You can be in Singapore.
You don't have to be restricted
to the confines of room 26-100,
right?
It's a very scalable tool.
And then in terms of movies,
I mean the thing about movies
is we have this culture where
people say that the attention
span for video is like less than
three minutes, yet you and I--
or at least I spend
$10 to sit for two,
three hours in a dark room.
And it's because movies are
these completely immersive
experiences that
give us a chance
to sort of escape
into this other world.
And you don't see
people paying $10
to sit in a room to listen
to a radio podcast, right?
There's something
about the integration
of the visual with the
storytelling and the acting
that totally immerses
you in this experience,
and that's a very, very powerful
element that video can do.
I also think it's a
window into a world
that you don't necessarily
have access to.
So whether it's
the world of 26-100
where Eric Lander is
teaching or if it's
the world of Middle
Earth-- I just
went and saw Hobbit III--
you get this chance to look
into this world that you
don't have access to,
and that's what video can do.
And then, finally, especially
in nonfiction video,
there's this idea of
the trusted guide, which
is a term that PBS Kids use
to think about new shows
that they pitch.
They think about
the person who's
going to be the host, that it's
more than just the person who's
going to stand and transfer
information to you.
It's someone who's
relatable, somebody
who's a role model,
someone who you really
trust, that you end
up really growing up
with people like Bill Nye.
I don't know if
you guys have shows
or show hosts that you
remember growing up as kids.
Mine was Jeff Corwin.
I'm like obsessed
with Jeff Corwin.
Does anyone have a
figure that they really
loved watching growing up?
Did anyone watch the old
Cosmos with Carl Sagan?
Yeah?
I feel like that's a
big one for people here.
So the trusted guide is
a really powerful thing
that video can leverage.
And I think that's a really
big reason why we're here,
at least the reason
why I'm here,
is because when you look at
the landscape of trusted guides
right now on especially
science and technical TV,
and not just TV but Hank Green
hosts SciShow on YouTube.
And the landscape of trusted
guide looks very homogeneous.
And I'm not saying that it's a
bad thing to be a guy at all,
but I do think that we have
this opportunity with video
to showcase who the scientists
and engineers really are.
And this landscape
is building a group
of advocates who
are going to be sort
of being the ambassadors to
the public about what you're
learning about and
what you're studying.
And we have this opportunity
to create a landscape that's
just as diverse as
the group of people
it's trying to represent.
And it's an opportunity that
I think hasn't necessarily
been capitalized upon.
Maybe it's because there
are political things
and it's hard to invest in a
figure that looks different
than the science hosts
that we're used to seeing.
But we have a chance here
at MIT where the people are
so diverse, not just in
ethnicity and gender,
but in background and
personalities and interests.
We have this huge landscape here
that we can tap into and start
contributing to a picture
that looks a little bit more
like what science and
engineering really is.
And the other thing is literacy
in digital media, which
is the whole idea
of understanding
your video product as
something more than the thing
that you just hit
play and watch,
or understanding making
video as something
more than just hitting
certain buttons to record
the present moment, is something
that is going to become
increasingly relevant.
I don't know you guys
UROP in labs or anything,
but a lot of labs right
now have their own cameras.
Many of you will
probably end up having
to give like a TED Talk
or some sort of talk
to the public where it's going
to be more than just conveying
information.
Like people were
saying, you want
to learn more
about how to engage
an audience in a way that is
going to inspire and engage
them.
So at the end of
the day, this class
is not about becoming
the next Bill Nye.
That title is just
totally clickbait
to get people to sign
up for the class.
And it's not even really
about making videos,
like I was saying.
The eventual deliverable
of this class,
the thing that we're
going to be working
towards every single
day of this month,
is to eventually create
around a three-minute episode
that you host, that
you're on camera for,
where you talk about a
science or technology
or engineering/math subject
or topic that you're
interested in.
So that's the
deliverable, it's a video.
But it's not
necessarily about what
are the technical steps
I need to get there.
Those are important,
but eventually it's
about taking those skills
of being a producer
and transferring them
into your everyday life.
So maybe some of you
won't make a video
after this month is
over, and that's OK,
but hopefully the skills
that you've picked up
along the way to becoming
an effective video producer
will help you become a
great advocate for science
and engineering later on.
Every video that you guys
will make in every assignment
that you make, and every
video that's online right now,
has different objectives.
Some of you may want to do a
video on physics, some of you
may want to talk about math.
But the thing that should
be the overarching objective
of everything you
make during this month
should be to address these
three problems in that amorphous
STEM blob that I was talking
about earlier, that you want
to open the door to
science and engineering,
and really love of
learning to everyone.
So a lot of that will
translate to making sure
that your script isn't
condescending to your audience,
making sure that
you're really meeting
and knowing your
audience where they
are, encouraging this
lifelong learning.
We want curiosity to drive a lot
of what your objectives should
be.
You want your audience
to become curious.
And then, of course,
we want your science
to be legit so you're
educating the public,
you're spreading STEM literacy.
What makes a good video?
Now, this is a quote from one
of the optional readings that's
listed on the syllabus.
It's actually really
great, we just
don't have time in
class to cover it.
But I love this quote.
"Learning how to make
really effective video
is like learning to
speak a second language.
You have to learn not just what
to say but how what you say
will be received by others.
We understand video
better than any humans
that have ever lived.
Most of us just
don't speak it well."
We consume video all the
time, like you were saying
you watch YouTube videos.
But that doesn't
necessarily transfer into us
knowing how to make videos.
It's the argument
of, oh, teaching
can't be that hard because
I've been a student
this whole time, right?
It's very hard to
extrapolate what
it is about the practice
of the video that
makes it good when all
you are used to doing
is being a consumer.
So what makes a great video?
Let's just take
this piece by piece
and look at best practices
in established video realm.
So educational videos.
There was this task
force that MITx
had a couple years
ago on what makes
an effective educational
video, and the four traits
that they came up with were,
one, that they were short,
that they were digestible
modules, usually
under 10 minutes.
Another is that the
learner could interact
with the speaker of the
video, so maybe the speaker
would mention a topic
and it would be something
that the viewer could end
up looking up on their own
and interacting with.
The other thing was that
the host had them engaged,
so it wasn't just this passive
recording of them rambling on
for an hour, the host would
actually tell the viewer,
OK, now try this problem
at home, for instance.
And then the host would
acknowledge the viewers,
so it wasn't just, here's
this math problem sent out
to this vague audience, it
was, you try this at home.
And this is also what a lot of
what I call explainer videos
do on YouTube.
I don't know-- you guys must
be familiar with Khan Academy,
but there are also things
like MIT BLOSSOMS, which
is a set of videos that's
developed by a group here.
There's Bozeman Science, who's
this high school teacher out
in Montana, and he does tutorial
videos on all the AP science
subjects.
Tyler DeWitt, a former
grad student here, he
does chemistry tutorial videos.
And they're all
very, very successful
because they take an
audience that's already
motivated in learning
something and they're
sort of one-stop shops.
So how do I calculate the
molar mass of this compound?
You can just go to
one of Tyler's videos
and learn how to do it.
It's very misleading sometimes,
though, because people see it
and they often mistake it for
it being a direct recording
of an instruction.
And so they say, oh,
these explainer videos
are much easier to do than
big budget productions.
And that's not necessarily true.
They still spend weeks
and weeks writing a script
and developing exactly
what they're going to say.
And they're so
effective because it's
a very talented host, a
very talented teacher who
is engaging their audience in
a way that helps them achieve
mastery of the subject.
So it gives them
learning confidence.
People love Sal Khan
because they really
feel connected to
him beyond sort
of this robotic voice that's
telling them how to calculate
the derivative of
something, and that's
a very intentional thing
I think that he does.
Now, for entertainment, even
within the world of YouTuber
or within the world of
entertaining videos,
there are subcategories that
have their own best practices.
But in general,
for entertainment,
the thing that is most
important, at least I think,
is building an emotional
connection with your audience.
And that's something that is
repeated by some of the folks
that I'll be quoting
in a little bit.
And in terms of
viral video, the way
to best establish that
emotional connection
is through authenticity.
By authenticity I
mean when you see
a video that goes
viral on YouTube,
it's not necessarily
something that
has a super corporate sheen.
It's not really polished.
A lot of times it just looks
like a very janky video
that someone took
with their iPhone.
And that in some
ways helps people
feel really connected to the
material that they're watching.
And you have to be
careful with it.
But I did want to show a couple
clips of two science videos
that have each raked-- I
think the first one has
over six million
and the second one
has almost 10 million views.
And we'll just
watch part of each.
CRAZY RUSSIAN HACKER: All
right, here is what we need.
Empty soda cans and put
a little bit of water.
Just a little bit, so it
will boil down, you know?
And then turn on the stove.
While this gets ready we're
going to make a nice bowl.
So right here we've got
our ice water already.
And you see how water is
boiling and steam coming out.
I don't know if you can
see it, but this steam
is coming out right now.
So we're going to
get it and drop it.
Use the tongs, don't use hands.
Get it and drop it upside-down.
That kind of fell.
Let's start with this one.
So are you guys ready?
You see?
They called this implosion.
I want you to tell
me why that happens.
Why does it implode like that?
So we've got this pan.
Here you go, a pan.
And just we're going
to turn this on.
But remember, safety is first.
Kids, you're going to
need adults' permission.
So and there we're going
to leave it for a minute.
We're going to put a
little bit of water.
Do you see how water is boiling
now because it's too hot?
So all the water is
gone, boiled out.
And let's leave it for
another two minutes.
So it's been about two minutes.
You see how hot it is?
Let's put just a little bit
of water, just little drops.
You see how all these drops just
like spinning around and not
boiling out?
I want you to comment
and tell me why.
Let's drop some more.
ELIZABETH CHOE: So the
thing is like 10 minutes
long so I'm not
going to show it.
But this video, which I
personally cannot stand
watching, this thing has
gotten over five million views
on YouTube.
And Crazy Russian Hacker,
who's the user who created it,
he has millions and
millions of subscribers.
I have the co-worker
whose son is 12 years old
and he loves Crazy
Russian Hacker.
And I don't know how you
guys feel about the video.
Were there any certain elements
that you noticed about it
that either you liked
or you understood why
people would like it so much?
Yes, John.
JONATHAN: He asked the audience
to explain what was going on,
so that encouraged
feedback and more posts
by commenting on the video.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Yeah,
so there's that element
of not only acknowledging
your audience but engaging it.
And that's something that
a lot of YouTube videos do.
Maybe it's to get more
comments, but it certainly
works a lot of the time.
Yes.
PAUL FOLINO: That
video seemed like it
was kind of-- it wasn't
necessarily scripted,
so it kind of shows
that he really
knows what he's talking
about, he's not robotically
following a script.
Shows he knows a little
bit about what he's doing.
ELIZABETH CHOE: And
he's quite a character.
I mean, Crazy Russian Hacker
has a huge brand, right?
Like as soon as
he starts talking
you know that it's a Crazy
Russian Hacker video.
And he's kind of outrageous.
Which is why it's
hard to repeat that.
It would be hard--
if I replicated
that exact same video, it
would probably not go viral.
So his whole persona
and the way that he
has this sort of unpolished
look about his videos
is actually maybe one of the
reasons why it's compelling.
Were you going to say
something, Yuliya?
YULIYA KLOCHAN: Yeah, I
think it's also relatable.
He dropped the can
the first time,
so that tells the viewers that
they can also make mistakes.
ELIZABETH CHOE: A
lot of online videos
have this single-take format.
So instead of having two
cameras like these guys
set up where you're switching
back and forth between angles,
he kind of just held his
iPhone where he was, right,
or whatever camera,
and followed along.
So you actually feel like
you're right there with him.
You feel like you're in
the kitchen with him.
There are no cuts back
and forth to him talking.
It's just one long,
continuous take
with just a couple mess-ups
taken out in between.
JOSH CHEONG: Even though
he asked comments,
I'm very sure these comments
are not all legitimate comments.
I've very sure there will be
probably one or two people who
purposely are trolls
and probably say,
oh, this is black
magic or something,
and then someone will comment,
and the virality probably
gives him the extra
few million views.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Yeah, yeah.
Logan Smalley, who's the
head of TED-Ed-- you guys
have seen TED Talks, right?
Have you ever seen
TED-Ed videos?
They do a spin-off where they
have animators and writers
partner up.
He's the one who
directs TED-Ed, and he
had this talk where he was
saying how a video online has
a beginning, middle, and end,
but the beginning, middle,
and end isn't what's
in the video itself.
The beginning is the tweet
that announces the video,
the middle is the video
itself, and the end
it is all the
conversation that takes
place afterwards in the comments
online and social media.
And so with things like
Crazy Russian Hacker,
the end, the conversation,
is almost just as important
or just as much a
part of the experience
as the 10-minute video itself.
I wanted to show
you one other video.
This is from Smarter Every
Day, and this has also
over five million views.
DESTIN SANDLIN: Hey,
it's me, Destin.
Welcome back to
Smarter Every Day.
So you've probably observed
that cats almost always
land on their feet.
Today's question is why.
Like most simple questions,
there's a very complex answer.
For instance, let me
reword this question.
How does a cat go
from feet up to feet
down in a falling
reference frame
without violating the
conservation of angular
momentum?
Now, I've studied free-falling
bodies-- my own, in fact--
in several different
environments.
And once I get my angular
rotation started in one
direction, I can't stop it.
Today we're going to
use a high-speed camera.
We're not going to use Ally
because this is my daughter's
cat, I don't want to hurt it.
We're going to use a stunt cat.
Let me introduce you
to Gigi, the stunt cat.
I'll just flip
the video vertical
and then motion-track the cat.
It's just going to take a
lot more effort in post.
We're going to try to
do it in a way that
doesn't make anybody mad.
That's pretty hard to do.
You got to drop a cat.
Ready, Gigi?
Checking out the high-speed
data there, Gigi?
OK, the first thing a cat
does when it's falling
is try to figure
out which way is up.
It does this either with a gyro
in the ear or with its eyes.
Ready to talk cat physics?
All right.
So check out this footage I
captured with the Phantom Miro
while Gigi goes to
get a drink of water.
So here's what's interesting
about this to me.
If you'll notice, at the
beginning of the drop
the cat is not rotating.
Halfway through the drop
the cat is rotating,
and then at the very end
Gigi somehow stops rotating.
Newton's first law says
that an object at rest
will stay at rest unless
acted on by an external force.
I see no external
forces on this cat.
So what's happening here?
It's not making sense to me.
OK, so in order to really
get the right data,
we're going to have to drop
her 90 degrees out of phase.
Ready, girl?
This time watch her tail.
Three, two, one.
OK, so you think
you figured it out?
Check this out.
You probably noticed that when
the cat was falling her tail
was rotating in the
direction opposite of where
her body was rotating.
What's interesting about that
is that that's not how it works.
In fact, even bobtail
cats can do this.
It's called the cat
righting reflex.
I'll prove it to you.
I came across some
video from the '60s
when the Air Force was
researching microgravity
for future astronauts.
Turns out they took some
cats up on parabolic flights.
He turns to rotate his tail to
flip over, but it doesn't work.
He just ends up nutating wildly.
Then he does
something interesting.
He takes his back
and he bends it.
And when he bends his back
and then creates motion,
something interesting happens.
Ahhh, now we're
getting somewhere.
So let me show you one
more cat flip with the Miro
and we'll figure this out.
OK, the arched back ends
up being pretty important.
What he does is he
divides his body up
into two separate
rotational axes that
are tilted from one another.
When he's released, he
pulls his front paws in
and does the ice skater trick.
He decreases his moment
of inertia in the front
so he can spin fast up there.
But in the back he pushes
his legs away from him,
increasing his
moment of inertia.
So a really large
twist in the front
equals a really small
twist in the back
in the opposite direction,
and the torques equal out.
So as soon as he gets his
front paws in under him,
all he has to do is
extend those legs back out
to increase that
moment of inertia
and stop the front twist,
and extend his back legs
along that rear axis.
That allows him to twist
those around really fast.
And then all he has
to do is pull them
back in under his body and
then extend all four legs,
and brace for impact.
ELIZABETH CHOE:
All right, so very
different from Crazy Russian
Hacker but just as popular.
I personally really
like Smarter Every Day.
I think he's one of
the best hosts, period.
You can disagree with
me, that's totally fine.
But the thing I like about
him is even though he's
maybe a little bit
more scripted--
he doesn't say um a
lot, he doesn't really
mess up as much-- I still feel
like Destin is talking to me,
that it's just this random
guy in his backyard.
He happens to be a
rocket scientist down
at NASA or some similar
engineering firm in Alabama,
so he obviously knows
his stuff very well.
But there's something
about him that's still
very relatable, very natural.
He seems like who
he is on screen
is who he is in real life.
Did anyone have any particular
aspects about that video
that they liked or disliked?
Or anything that they noticed?
KENNETH CHEAH: I
think he thought
about how [INAUDIBLE] tail
was what affected the cat's
movement, allowed the cat to--
but he mentioned that it wasn't
the tail at all,
so then that made
us more interested in wanting
to finish the rest of the video.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Mm-hm.
He anticipated the misconception
[INAUDIBLE] the cat.
And that's actually
a really big tool
that you can use in your
videos to hook people in.
And Ceri, you take that
summer MIT course, right?
Where you were
specifically addressing
misconceptions in biology?
CERI RILEY: Yeah, I actually
took a summer class at MIT,
and I personally made a video.
But our whole
objective of the class
was to choose a topic in
science that people often
have misconceptions about.
So some people did videos
on you catch a cold
if you're outside in the cold.
And then mine was your
deoxygenated blood
in diagrams is
always shown as blue
and so people think our
blood is blue sometimes,
but it's always
different shades of red.
Yeah, and so our entire goal
was to figure out not only
the real science
behind the topic,
but how to explain
it in a way that
debunks the myths or
the misconceptions
that people have about them.
ELIZABETH CHOE: And
I don't know what
it is about
misconceptions, but it
does seem to be something
that not necessary predicates
but can help launch a video into
being something more engaging.
And maybe it is because it
taps into the audience itself
and it becomes more relatable,
because it's acknowledging,
hey, this is what
you actually think.
And it becomes
surprising and maybe
more memorable in that way.
That you're more likely to
remember that a cat doesn't use
its tail to sort of
out-balance the rotation
that it feels when it's flipping
but actually scrunches up.
I mean, I'm going to
remember that way more
than I'm going to remember a
single one of my 801 lectures
on rotational physics.
So that's just something
to think about.
Now, something I
do want to mention,
and this is a conversation
that Chris and I have
a lot, which is that people
often confuse correlation
for causation, right?
They think, oh, well, all
these videos did really well
so I just need to
make a crappy video
and do really bad
lighting and just
be really terrible on
camera, and it'll go viral,
it'll be great.
It'll be relatable
and authentic.
And that's not
necessarily true, right?
Low production value
is not equal to
and does not predict
a viral video.
If any of us tried to
recreate Crazy Russian Hacker
it would probably not go
viral for the same reasons
that I talked about
earlier, which
is that there are a
lot of elements that
go in play into creating
something beyond what you see
on screen when
you're watching it.
That it's OK to have
good production.
Smarter Every Day is
actually pretty decent,
and when you see his newer
videos, his camera work,
it's pretty good.
And you can tell that he's
gotten new equipment and things
like that.
And it doesn't take away
at all from the experience,
from the authenticity
of the video.
That authenticity starts
at the core of the host,
at the way they're
creating it, the reasons
why they're creating the video.
And it's not created by the
conditions of the production
itself, necessarily.
It's just that the conditions
don't hinder the authenticity.
But please don't mistake.
Bad video production does not
help you get to viral video.
It just doesn't stop
you from getting there.
Now, for YouTube-- and we sort
of previewed this a little bit
with the two videos
that we watched--
there are a couple traits
about YouTube videos
that I think make them
really great for learning
and for educating,
and for successfully
engaging an audience.
The first being just
sort of the format
in which they're written.
A lot of viral YouTube videos
or videos that are well known,
or a lot of SciShow
videos, for instance,
they follow this format
of asking the why, what,
and how questions.
So you'll notice that the
Smarter Every Day video was not
titled gravitational
physics, Newton's second law,
or rotational dynamics, right?
It was why does a cat fall on
its feet when it falls down,
right?
It's contextualizing
the question.
It's making it relatable.
It's sort of tapping
into the innate curiosity
that people have, even
if they hate science.
People who watch that video
are not physics majors.
And it makes them more sharable.
It makes them more memorable.
And I think it makes it a
little bit more conducive
to this idea of
retrieval learning,
that people aren't going to
just end the video right there,
right?
They're going to maybe
share it with their friends
or they're going
to talk about it
with their teacher at school.
Which is such a powerful
thing to happen with learning.
I think that's what really
everyone's objective is
as a teacher, or
a lot of teachers
have this objective, that
they don't want the lessons
that they're
teaching to just stop
once people leave the room.
They want people to
keep thinking about it
and thinking about it in
the context of their life
outside of the classroom.
So this format really
aids in doing that.
And I have a couple
of videos I want
to show you guys, the first
being from AsapSCIENCE.
ASAPSCIENCE: Ahhh, sleep.
You can never have
enough of it, it seems.
In fact, sometimes
it literally feels
like you aren't getting enough.
But what if you stopped
sleeping altogether?
Strangely, science
understands relatively
little about why we sleep or how
it evolved in the first place.
After all, laying unconscious
and dormant for hours on end
while predators lurk hardly
seems advantageous or smart.
But we have discovered
a few correlations.
For example, adults who sleep
between six to eight hours
a night tend to live longer.
Excessive sleep, however,
can lead to medical problems,
including cardiovascular
disease and diabetes.
Similarly, chronic
sleep deprivation
has been linked to aspects
of cardiovascular disease,
obesity, depression,
and even brain damage.
But what if you stopped
sleeping right now?
Well, after your first sleepless
night, your mesolimbic system
becomes stimulated and
dopamine runs rampant.
And this may actually trigger
some extra energy, motivation,
positivity, and even sex drive.
Sounds appealing, but
it's a slippery slope.
Your brain slowly
begins to shut off
the regions responsible
for planning and evaluating
decisions, leading to
more impulsive behavior.
Once exhaustion sets
in, you'll find yourself
with slower reaction
times, and reduced
perceptual and
cognitive functions.
After a day or two
of no sleep, the body
loses its ability to
properly metabolize glucose,
and the immune system
stops working as well.
In some cases, three
days of no sleep
has led to hallucinations.
Care about how you look?
Studies have shown
a direct correlation
between sleep deprivation and
a person's perceived beauty.
That is to say,
sleep-deprived individuals
appeared less healthy and
less attractive than when
they were well-rested.
The longest scientifically
documented case of being awake
was 264 hours, or 11 days.
And while they did
develop problems
with concentration,
perception, and irritability,
the surprising
truth is that they
suffered no serious
long-term health effects.
In fact, no individuals under
these documented conditions
experienced medical,
physiological, neurological,
or psychiatric problems.
But there are limited
studies, and this
doesn't mean permanent
damage couldn't
be inflicted with more time.
Sleep deprivation experiments
on rats, for example,
generally lead to death
after about two weeks.
But scientists
aren't totally sure
if they're dying from
the lack of sleep
or from the stress of
constantly being woken up.
Perhaps we should look at
fatal familial insomnia
for an answer, a rare
genetic disease of the brain
which causes progressively
worsening insomnia,
or sleeplessness, leading
to hallucinations, dementia,
and ultimately death.
This disease has only affected
around 100 people in the world,
but their average survival
span was around 18 months.
Over time, the lack
of sleep becomes worse
and the body's organs
begin to shut down.
So while lack of sleep won't
necessarily kill you quickly,
continual sleep
deprivation will have
a negative effect on your body.
Sleep tight.
But not too much.
Got a--
ELIZABETH CHOE: So were there
any elements of that video
that you found striking, that
you liked, that you disliked?
Yes, Yuliya.
YULIYA KLOCHAN: I really
liked the movement
and that he changed
his materials.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Oh, like from
drawing to construction paper
and things like that.
What did you think
about the animation?
Did you like it or not?
JOSH GUNN: Oh,
are you asking me?
ELIZABETH CHOE: Yeah.
JOSH GUNN: Yeah, I
think it's effective.
I think one of the things
about it that's nice
is that the animation allowed
him to change to appeal to I
think a current need for a
constant stream of images
that are different.
This kind of-- I think
we've been conditioned
to be sort of
bombarded with images,
and animation is great for that.
ELIZABETH CHOE: I
mean, I personally
am not a huge fan of
AsapSCIENCE style,
but I also recognize
why it's super effective
and why other people
would like it.
Because like you said,
it's very engaging,
if only for just the visual--
JOSH GUNN: It's also
really well written.
I actually think
that it's better
written than it
is-- I mean, I think
there are any number of ways
it could have been performed.
But I think it's
really well written.
It's very concise.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Right.
It's very shareable.
It's sort of written
in this listicle form
that is dominating
web media in general.
It's like basically
taking a BuzzFeed article
and putting it into a video.
Yet with the visual
elements, there
is a motivation for you
to watch versus just
see it on text form, in
BuzzFeed, for instance.
JOSH GUNN: I actually thought
that the cat video lost
some of its
engagement for me when
he was-- there was
this sort of stream
of scientific information
and all you're doing
is just watching this
cat in slow motion.
And for me, it lost that
kind of key component
of what makes something
engaging, which
is the tight cohesion
between what you're seeing
and what's being said.
And also the streamlining
of scripting.
ELIZABETH CHOE:
And that's always
going to be a push-and-pull
that everyone's
going to experience, too,
with-- at some point,
are you explaining too
much to the viewer?
Should you just
rely on the visual?
Because you don't
want to be too jargony
and end up alienating an
audience, but at the same time
you have to cover-- you can't
cover everything, right?
You can't go in it in detail
and explain everything.
And that's a conflict that
we'll hit in later lectures,
how you can use
animation to help you
with that, some of the best
practices in that realm.
But that is something
to think about,
and I think that's a struggle
that everyone has with video,
for sure.
I have one more video.
Did anyone else
want to say anything
about what would happen
if you didn't sleep?
Yes.
JAIME GOLDSTEIN: You
know, I was watching
and I was thinking
because so much
of it is being shown
just sort of from Gary
of these pictures
and these words,
the thing that Crazy Russian
Hacker had and the cat guy had
that this guy doesn't is that
you know they're not making
anything up because
you can see the cat
and you can see the
bubbles, whereas there
are no references,
so how do I know
that everything
that is being said
is based on fact
upon fact upon fact.
He could be making all of
this up, for all I know.
And as I was watching
it, I was thinking,
how do I know he's not-- like
where's the truth in here?
I don't know.
JOSH GUNN: Yeah, there
is some of that element
of like the web has a lot of
information but what of it
is validated, or where
does it come from.
JAIME GOLDSTEIN: If there were
a little subtext somewhere even
just referencing
any of the ideas,
I'd feel more like, all
right, I can believe this guy.
But as it is, it's
hard, because you just
have a whiteboard and a
marker, and you think, well,
how do I know they've
done their research.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Right.
And I mean, with
YouTube channels,
a lot of them put in the
sources in their descriptions.
But I think the thing that maybe
I enjoy less about AsapSCIENCE
is you could switch the creator
out for any other person
and have any-- you could have
Siri from your phone narrate
the video for you and it
wouldn't be a completely
different experience.
I mean, it has its branding
because it was really
one of the first
channels to do that style
of hand-drawn animation,
so that's its thing.
But it doesn't have the
compelling sort of authenticity
that Crazy Russian
Hacker does, or Smarter
Every Day, or SciShow.
And I think a lot of it is
because you don't see someone
on screen, you don't
see a person on screen.
And maybe that's just
my personal taste,
but I do think that makes
a really big difference.
This video is from Vsauce.
Has anyone ever seen
that channel before?
Yeah.
So I actually haven't
watched all of this video
by myself because
I was scared to,
but this is why I
think it's creepy.
MICHAEL STEVENS: Hey,
Vsauce, Michael here.
Fear gives us life.
Being afraid of the right
things kept our ancestors alive.
It makes sense to be
afraid of poisonous insects
or hungry tigers.
But what about fear when there
is no clear and obvious danger?
For instance, a teddy bear
with a full set of human teeth.
ELIZABETH CHOE: I can't.
MICHAEL STEVENS: A smile.jpg.
There's something a little
off about these images.
Too much mystery
and strangeness.
But no obvious
threat the way there
is with a gun or a falling rock.
But yet they still incite
fear because they are creepy.
But why?
What gives us the creeps?
What causes something
to be creepy?
We are now in my
bedroom, the bedroom
I grew up in, in Kansas.
Like a lot of children my age,
I was terrified of scary stories
to tell in the dark.
But the very first book
that ever scared me
was the Curse of the Squirrel.
To this day I still
haven't finished the book,
but that's just me.
Psychologist James
Geer developed the Fear
Survey Schedule-II,
which he used to find out
what scared us the most.
Combined with the results of
a more recent Gallup poll,
these are the things that
scare most of us the most.
All of these things are
scary, but are they creepy?
Let's get more specific.
I love the way Stephen
King delineates
three types of scary stuff.
The first is the gross-out.
This is something
disgusting, morbid, diseased.
The second is horror.
Horror, to King,
is the unnatural;
a giant spider or being
grabbed in the dark when
you thought you were alone.
The third, terror, is
different, creepier.
He says terror is
coming home to find
that everything that
you own has been
replaced with an exact copy.
Terror is feeling
something behind you,
its breath on your neck, knowing
that you will be grabbed,
but then turning around to find
that there was never anything
there in the first place.
Not a lot of research
has been done
on that feeling, the creeps.
But many theories and ideas
involve vagueness, ambiguity.
For instance, masks, and
why clowns are creepy.
Claude Levi-Strauss wrote that
the facial disguise temporarily
eliminates from
social intercourse
the part of the body which
reveals personal feelings
and attitudes.
Part of the reason even
a neutral or happy mask
can be creepy may have
to do with ambiguity.
A mask hides the true
emotions and intentions
of the person underneath.
I don't know if the person
wearing that mask is a threat
or not.
Vagueness is creep when it
comes to the human form.
This is the famous
uncanny valley.
On a chart of humanness,
there's a zone
where something can
be almost entirely
human but off by just a little.
Not so wrong that it's clear
fake or funny, or so good
that it's indistinguishable.
Instead, it's just troubling.
The creepiness of
the uncanny valley
is wonderfully demonstrated
by John Bergeron's singing
androids.
Watch these videos
when you're alone.
A similar uneasy feeling
comes from Shaye Saint John,
a character created
by Eric Fournier.
Funny to some, nightmare
fuel to others.
Uncanny humanoids,
like all creepy things,
straddle a line
between two regions
that we can understand
and explain with language.
Francis T. McAndrew
and Sara Koehnke
describe being creeped out
as an adaptive human response
to the ambiguity of
threats from others.
Creepy things are kind
of a threat maybe,
but they're also kind
of not, so our brains
don't know what to do.
Some parts respond with fear
while other parts don't, and
they don't know why.
So instead of achieving a
typical fear response, horror,
we simply feel uneasy.
Terror.
Creeped out.
Between the mountains
of safety and danger,
there is a valley
of creepiness, where
the limits of our knowledge
and trust and security
aren't very clear.
Will looking at this cause
you to die one week later?
Impossible, right?
Maybe.
That's the terror of ambiguity.
We don't do well with ambiguity.
When it involves our own
intentions, it can make us lie.
And when it involves danger--
ELIZABETH CHOE: Can I stop or
you guys want to keep watching?
MICHAEL STEVENS: [INAUDIBLE]
recognizable threat,
it can make us think and
feel some pretty weird--
ELIZABETH CHOE: So he goes
on and talks more about
like the actual
psychology behind this.
The whole pop-up thing
is his trademark move.
He does that between
all of his transitions.
It's like a little
kitschy but it
works since he was
the first to do it.
But what did you guys
think about this one,
especially in comparison
to AsapSCIENCE?
Very similar format,
it's the why-what-how,
but executed very differently.
Or maybe was there
something about this video
that you liked better
than AsapSCIENCE
or that you disliked
compared to AsapSCIENCE.
Yep.
PAUL FOLINO: I think I got the
point maybe couple minutes in,
but it seemed like the
next three or four minutes,
he was just expounding on
that point that I already got.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Yeah, so it
dragged a little bit more.
PAUL FOLINO: Right, it never
really answered-- I mean,
you didn't finish the
video, but it never
seemed to answer the
question [INAUDIBLE].
ELIZABETH CHOE: Yeah.
I mean, he does
sort of eventually,
but it does take him a little
bit longer to get there.
Yes.
YULIYA KLOCHAN: It
still kept my attention
because he was very
close to the audience
and he was an
interesting character,
so I was interested
in knowing what
he would say next, [INAUDIBLE].
ELIZABETH CHOE: Yeah,
Michael Stevens definitely
is a very memorable
persona on screen.
And this is something
that we'll emphasize
throughout the course.
We don't want you
to feel like you
have to exaggerate
yourself or sort
of because this
persona on screen
that you're not naturally.
It's not about you
trying to adapt
into a Bill Nye personality
or into a Michael Stevens
personality.
A lot of people find
him super annoying,
and I don't blame them.
It's really about
how to best capture
who you are in real
life and just maintain
that as much as possible
in front of a camera,
because maybe he is a little
bit different in real life,
but it doesn't seem super
unnatural when you watch,
right?
You're not like, this
guy is acting just
like totally over the top.
It's just part of his
brand, part of his persona
to get his message across.
I do think that something
that was effective about that
video is it took all these
concepts that you learn
in cognitive
psychology, but again,
instead of doing
a video on here's
the definition of uncanny
valley or things like that,
he tapped into something
that resonates--
at least it resonates
a lot with me,
because I was super
creeped out by this video.
But it taps into something
that we experience every day,
that it's a very relatable
video, that it's contextual,
that I don't feel
like I'm watching
a lecture, necessarily, on it.
I don't feel like I'm even
watching a Khan Academy video.
That I just want to sit
there and learn more.
I wanted to learn more for the
first two minutes, at least.
I don't know if you
guys felt that way.
Yes, no?
Yeah.
JOSH CHEONG: I felt like
I got pretty much what--
after he showed me the
graph of the thing,
I didn't really
understand the graph,
but he kind of explained
it with like, oh,
you need to be in between
two points to be creepy.
Then after that, it's all about
trying to figure it myself.
He does this
connect-the-dots thing.
He doesn't really give
you the right answers.
He seems to be seeding you.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Yeah.
The payoff happened, but it
takes a long time to get there.
And maybe he loses
interest along the way.
Again, that's
something that you're
going to have to figure
out how to balance,
how much tension do you want
to build up for the audience.
Maybe you'll do it too much, to
the point where you lose them.
Maybe you do it to just create
the buildup to the final reveal
of your video.
In addition to being these
digestible, listicle type
chunks that are
shareable and contextual,
YouTube videos are also
super searchable, right?
So you can just go
on YouTube and search
for literally anything you
want, and you'll have suggested
videos that pop up at
the end, so there's
this sort of inherent--
what was the thing I put?
There's an inherent
vetting process
that happens on
YouTube, that you
have a compendium of
knowledge and compendium
of resources available
to you, and you
have things like
comments and suggested
views and subscriptions to
help you decide what to watch.
And everything's
at your fingertips.
You can get whatever you
want, whenever you want it.
Then there's this whole
trusted guide element
that is really-- it's
just as present on YouTube
as it is on TV.
You have people like
Vsauce and Michael Stevens.
Even with AsapSCIENCE,
you don't see the guy,
but it has a really
strong brand.
And it's one of
those things where
if you replaced a
successful YouTube
video with another person or
another narrator-- a litmus
test that I like to think
of is if you replace it
and it's just not really
a noticeable change,
then maybe there's
something with your video
that isn't very engaging.
That if you swapped out any
of your classmates for it
and it still sort of felt
like the same video, maybe
there's more of your
inherent personality
that you can highlight
more in the video.
And then, with YouTube, there's
no invisible college, right?
There's no gatekeeper
of knowledge.
You don't have to pay $100 to
access a lecture course, right?
Anybody can access
OpenCourseWare.
Anybody can go watch
a Vsauce video.
Anyone can comment, so
theoretically, anyone
can contribute to that community
and landscape, and its products
as well.
I think we're starting
to see more of it.
You see more female
creators, you
see a little bit more diversity
in the YouTube environment
than you do on TV, certainly.
But again, there's a lot of
room to grow in that regard.
And then finally,
for TV, TV is very
different from online
video, which is something
that I didn't actually realize
myself until fairly recently.
I always kind of
thought if I want
to make a good video online
then I should just sort of apply
the best practices of
making a good video on TV
and just shorten it to a
five-minute online video.
But that's not
necessarily the case,
because the priority
of TV, first of all,
is to hold your attention.
When you're watching TV, there
are going to be commercials,
you can flip the channel.
I guess you can do that
with online stuff as well,
but the distractions
aren't necessarily as huge.
When you go to a
commercial, you're
going to want to
change the channel.
So they really have to
hook your attention,
and they do that a lot with
some of the production styles.
On TV you'll tend to see a lot
more multi-camera type videos.
You'll see a lot of quick
cuts, a lot of effects
to sort of keep you engaged.
I noticed that about the Hobbit,
there was like an explosion
every other second.
And they do that
because they have
to have this really
big hold on you
for a much longer
period of time.
Whereas on online videos,
stuff like Smarter Every Day,
it's just kind of the
same camera set up
on a tripod that's shooting
you the whole time.
And TV is very much
about narrative,
about telling a story.
And I think that
that is something
that you should do in an online
video too, but it's not as much
of a necessity.
Things like-- I don't know,
any viral video that's
not necessarily
science-related, most of them
don't really have a story.
It's more just like,
here's a naked celebrity.
I guess you could create
a story out of it,
but it's not
narrative-driven, necessarily,
whereas TV very much is,
and movies are as well.
I wanted to show
you another video,
and this is from
Connections, which I never
heard of until Chris showed
us this show in his class.
But it's awesome.
It's like one of the first
science TV shows in the UK.
And this is from Connections 2,
and it's a whodunnit episode.
JAMES BURKE: I suppose a
detective catches a crook
because he follows a trail from
one uniquely relevant event
or person to another,
until he finds
a unique piece of
evidence that points
to the only person in the world
who could've done the deed.
And strangely
enough, the story I'm
about to tell you about
why modern detectives are
able to do that at all follows
exactly the same kind of tail,
from one unique character
to another through history.
Here's my first
unique character,
Steve Davis, one of the best
snooker players in the world.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Ah,
don't look at this.
So that is a show that
aired-- I don't know,
was that like the '70s?
CHRIS BOEBEL: It's the
late '70s [INAUDIBLE].
ELIZABETH CHOE: Late '70s?
And this is Connections 2,
so maybe it's early '80s.
I don't know about you, I
felt like that was so endless.
It took him two whole minutes
to even just introduce
the first character of
what he was talking about,
and it felt--
CHRIS BOEBEL: Isn't it
amazing how the pacing has
changed, and our expectations?
ELIZABETH CHOE: Right, it
felt agonizing, almost.
And I'm sure if I watched it
on TV and I saw the rest of it,
it would be fine.
But I mean, compare that to
AsapSCIENCE, for instance.
The priority of what
Connections producers were
doing with that video is very
different than AsapSCIENCE,
and you have a very
different effect.
I actually really
enjoyed Connections,
I really liked the show too.
So I'm not saying it's a
bad thing, necessarily.
But that's sort of what happens
when you're applying this best
practices in TV
or movies and you
think you can just move it
over to video on the web
and just shorten it down.
That's not necessarily going
to be the best approach,
because some of
the best practices
aren't going to
work, necessarily.
So what I would
like you guys to do
right now, if you can
access-- does everyone
have a laptop with them or can
share a laptop with someone?
If you go onto our class
site, it's mit219.tumblr.com.
You'll see a post that I
just put up earlier today,
and it has a link to a Google
doc that should look like this.
Should look like this.
And what I'd like you guys to
do for maybe the next like 20-25
minutes-- and feel free to get
up and stretch during this time
if you want.
If you need to use the
restroom, feel free to head out.
JAIME GOLDSTEIN: Can you
write the URL on the board?
ELIZABETH CHOE: Oh, yeah.
Can everyone see on this board?
There should only be
one post, and it'll
have a link to
the class syllabus
that, again, has all the
videos that we've watched today
and the assignments
for all the days.
And then it should have a
link to this Google doc.
And what I'd like
for you guys to do
is to watch the videos
that I've listed here,
and then record the exact
time code in which you
want to stop watching the video,
and just be completely honest.
And then afterwards we'll talk
about maybe some of the reasons
why you thought certain
videos were more engaging.
Think about why you might still
think that a video is good even
if you wanted to turn it off.
And we'll convene at the end.
But again, feel free--
if you guys need
to get up and stretch or go to
the bathroom during this time,
feel free to do that too.
And you guys can talk
to each other as well.
All right, let's
go ahead and talk.
I know you guys
are finishing up.
Just so you know, every day
you'll do blog reflections,
and if you want to talk a little
bit more about your thoughts
on these videos in your blog
today, that's totally fine.
I know we're not going
to get everything.
But did anyone have
a favorite video?
Yes.
ANDREA DESROSIERS:
The Veritasium one.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Oh, Veritasium,
you like that one the best?
Yeah, actually, that
one's my favorite too.
ANDREA DESROSIERS: And Asap.
ELIZABETH CHOE: And Asap.
What about those two videos
did you like, or maybe
can you hit upon one thing
that you found particularly--
ANDREA DESROSIERS: Veritasium,
very charismatic host,
and kept the pace
not going so quickly,
but not going too slowly.
Then for AsapSCIENCE,
it was very crisp
and conveyed the point very
succinctly and clearly.
ELIZABETH CHOE: That's
interesting because I actually
thought that those were the
two videos that I personally
watched most of myself.
And I'm not necessarily the
biggest fan of AsapSCIENCE,
but I did want to
watch the whole thing.
The thing about
Veritasium is interesting,
because he's not using super
fancy equipment, per se.
His stuff looks a lot
better than a lot of what's
on YouTube, but he's using just
basic DSLR cameras, I think.
But his background, he's a
physicist, that's his PhD.
But he does physics
education as well,
so he's very cognizant of the
role of video in education,
and that's going to be one
of your reading assignments
tonight, is watching
one of his videos.
But I do think that he does a
very interesting job and a very
good job of being very natural
on screen, charismatic,
like you were saying.
There's something
about his delivery
that is-- he talks the way that
you would think he would just
talk in real life,
which is actually
really hard to do on video.
Did anyone else-- let's
see what you guys thought
about the Veritasium video.
It looks like a lot of people
actually finished that one.
And I didn't mention this
before, but maybe you noticed.
All these videos are
talking about evolution
or natural selection
in some way or another,
but they're doing it
very different ways.
What about anyone
else, let's see.
Nathan, you finished SciShow.
What was it about
SciShow that you liked?
NATHAN HERNANDEZ:
I'd say I liked
that there's a little bit
of humor in his video.
I think that's
something that tends
to keep my attention better.
ELIZABETH CHOE:
Sorry, that you what?
NATHAN HERNANDEZ:
Just when you have
a little bit of humor inserted,
that keeps my attention better.
ELIZABETH CHOE: And Hank Green
is a very neurotic host, right?
He talks like this
and he has quick cuts
and he's very
hyper all the time,
and it works for him
because that's just
who he is in real life.
So again, being Hank Green
doesn't make you successful,
it's that he's able to just be
himself on camera that works.
Did anyone have a least favorite
video or one-- let's see,
a lot of people
ended the TED-Ed one,
or maybe a couple people
ended that one early,
and the Khan Academy one early.
Any thoughts about those?
What is it that made
you-- I keep doing that.
What is it about
those videos that
made you turn them off early?
Paul, you turned that
one off at 17 seconds.
That's pretty early.
PAUL FOLINO: What one?
ELIZABETH CHOE: The
Khan Academy one.
PAUL FOLINO: Oh, yeah.
I just thought that was a bad
way of portraying evolution.
I usually use Khan Academy
for math or something
like that, because he is going
through all the hand motions
and how to do an equation.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Right.
PAUL FOLINO: But I think
something like evolution
that's kind of nebulous to begin
with, I'd like to see pictures,
not really-- I don't know.
That's just my personal opinion.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Well,
yeah, I personally
agree with that as well.
I mean, I also feel
like Khan Academy works
for a very certain
type of video,
and that tends to be a
numbers and graph-driven one.
And we'll talk about this
more in a little bit,
but when you think about why
you want to make a video,
you have to consider quite
a bit about the visuals
that you're going to
use and how that's
going to motivate the story
that you're going to tell,
or trying to convey the message
that you're trying to convey.
And I know-- I wish we
could talk a little bit more
about this, but we are running
a little bit short on time
and I want to leave
enough room for Chris.
So if you can respond
a little bit more
in your blog reflection tonight
about some of these videos,
that would be awesome.
So we've hit upon
some qualities of what
makes a good video, a
good educational video,
a good YouTube video,
a good TV video.
But the question of
what is good, right?
Because ultimately
we have to figure out
what we're going to define
as success in this class,
because otherwise there's going
to be no impetus to improve.
It's a really hard question,
because what is good
is really intangible.
It's really inaccessible, at
least in the field of video,
or whatever we're going to try
to do, because what is good
is very much a matter of
personal taste, right?
Like I personally don't really
like the AsapSCIENCE videos,
but I recognize them as
being successful in what
they're doing.
They're engaging people,
they're spreading STEM literacy,
they're getting
people to be curious.
I'm not sure how much they're
opening the door to science,
but I mean they're doing
good things even if I
don't personally enjoy them.
And a lot of people love
Hank Green from SciShow
and a lot of people think
he's super annoying.
So again, it's really hard
to define what is good.
We often try to approximate
what is good by other measures,
so a lot of times
we'll look at virality,
how many views it has, how
many subscribers they have.
But again, virality is something
that you can sort of assess
in retrospect but
it's not necessarily
the most predictive measure,
because so much of it
rests on confounding
variables like what
are the current events that
are happening at the time
that the video comes out,
what's the personality like.
Have you guys ever seen
the OK Go music videos?
So they're this popular
alternative band,
and their big breakout
video was them
doing this huge choreographed
dance on four treadmills.
And ever since then
they've sort of
tried to do this similar
thing of a single take shot.
I didn't actually show
any of the videos,
but I can send you
guys the links later.
They do these single cam,
continuous shots of just
like outrageous dances,
and I don't even
know how to describe them.
But the first one was the
one where they struck gold.
And they repeated the same
thing, it was the same people,
but their later ones,
which are successful,
aren't nearly as successful
as that treadmill one.
So there are qualities
about viral video
that are universal,
things like authenticity.
A naked celebrity is
always going to go viral.
But it's very hard to build
a predictive model based off
of a regression that you're
looking at in the past.
And then you have things
like learning objectives
that you can use to
qualify something as good.
You can say, oh, this video
hit upon all to the standards
that seventh graders in the
US need to know about biology
so it's a good video,
and maybe that's
why Bozeman Science--
maybe that's
why he makes good videos.
But it only tells so
much of the picture.
So what is going to be
our definition of good?
And this is a question that
I still am struggling with
and I am totally
open to us discussing
as the class progresses.
But I do think that
there are going
to be certain qualities that we
should strive for, regardless
of if your taste is in
really rapid delivery
or if it's in very sort of
philosophical, grandiose type
videos.
This is a quote from a
reading that you guys
are going to annotate on
tonight for your homework,
from Hank Green, who's
the host of SciShow.
But he says, "People who are
new to the medium are starting
to think that online video is
not 'Just a little bit better
than everything else on YouTube'
but 'Just a little bit worse
than everything
that's on TV.'" And,
"That perspective is a super
dangerous road to go down on."
That's sort of hitting upon
what I was saying earlier about
you can't take necessarily the
best practices in the realms
that we're trying to combine and
transfer them over and expect
great results, right?
You can't try to
make a video like you
would TV show, necessarily.
So what is good?
If good isn't the combined
practices of TV, education,
YouTube, what is
good going to be?
So this is a viral
video manifesto that's,
again, optional reading.
It's actually pretty good.
It's from the guys who made
the Diet Coke and Mentos video?
Have you ever seen
it, where they combine
Mentos and Diet Coke and
there's this huge, choreographed
explosion?
They talk about four points.
Be true, be authentic.
Don't waste our time.
On an online video,
you can't afford
to do what Connections did
and take two whole minutes
to set up the premise,
because that's sometimes
the entirety of a video.
Be unforgettable,
show us something
that we've never seen before.
And that honestly might be
the hardest thing for us
here, at least it
was the hardest thing
for a lot of the students that
we worked with on the first two
seasons of Science Out Loud,
that it's very hard to take
yourself out of the perspective
of being an MIT student,
or being a student involved
in science and engineering.
And remember that some
of the things that you
take for granted and are
part of your everyday life
are actually really awesome
and really cool, and things
that most people
don't see every day.
You may work at
the nuclear reactor
here and think that it's
just another everyday thing,
but that's a window
that you can create
for people who would have
never, ever had access to it.
And then ultimately,
it's about humanity,
about the emotional connection.
A lot of that comes
from the authenticity,
that if we can swap you out
with just the computer voice
and there's not that much
of a difference, then
really rethink how you're
structuring and writing
and producing your video.
So there are going to be
four course values that'll
guide all of the assignments
and all the things that we do.
And the rubric is listed in the
syllabus that's on the website.
We don't really
assign point values
to did you do correct
lighting, did you do this,
did you set up your
camera the right way,
because we don't want
you guys to get bogged
down in the minutia of it.
Instead, there are going to be
these four overarching values
that'll dictate what
is good, I guess,
as we move along in the class.
The first one is Spark.
There's this quote, and
I think it's by Fellini,
but something along
the lines of it's
not what's inside the
camera that matters,
so much as what's in
front of and behind it.
So are you promoting curiosity?
Is there a perceived love
of learning in your product?
Right, is there a perceived love
Is your passion and joy
evident in your delivery?
This can be seen in your
script, in your final video.
This doesn't mean that you
need to go over the top.
It doesn't mean that you
have to pretend to be someone
that you're naturally not or you
don't feel comfortable being.
But I'm sure all
of us in this room
have something that
they're excited about,
so can we perceive that
excitement in your product?
Clarity.
So "Kill all of your darlings"
is one of my favorite sayings
and something that dictates
a lot of the work that I do.
But this will be learning how to
navigate the material you have
and getting rid of stuff, maybe
getting rid of explanations
that don't need to be there.
Editing is going to
be a lot about this,
and the last lecture is
a lot about this quote.
But it's also about can
you convey your message
in the most clear manner?
Is your script tightly written?
Is your delivery engaging?
Have you realized your vision
as effectively as possible?
Then we have
thoughtfulness, which
is that every decision matters.
Whether it's deciding
what background you're
going to stand in front of to
deliver one of your scenes,
or deciding what facts to
include in your final script,
every single decision matters.
And it's thoughtfulness
about what
you decide to put in
front of the camera,
but also how you decide
to talk to your audience.
And again, it's outlined
more in the rubric.
And then go big or go home.
This is a hard one for
people, understandably.
This is probably the
hardest one for me.
But learning how to step
outside your comfort zone
and getting creative.
We do you want to
reward creative risks,
so don't feel like you
can't try something new.
Again, hopefully it's
an educated risk.
But these are all
qualities that we're
going to assess, not only
through your final products
but through your
daily reflections,
through a lot of the
iterative processes that
will be happening on the
way to your final products.
And this is where we're
going to integrate things
like are things clearly lit,
but in the context of was
this a clear message.
Does that makes
sense to everyone?
So if you want to make a
video, where do you start?
The first thing is deciding
if you should make a video.
And I think this
list of questions
is one that everyone
should ask themselves
before they make a video.
Why am I making a video
in the first place,
versus a BuzzFeed article
or versus a radio piece?
Who is going to
watch this video?
This will make a
very big difference
in how you decide to
write your script,
how you decide to deliver.
For the most part,
our assignments
will be assuming sort of a
middle school type science
background.
What visuals will I show?
Again, this makes a
really big difference.
As Paul was saying, the Khan
Academy video didn't really
have the visuals that motivated
the lesson that he was wanting
to learn, so thinking about what
visuals you're going to show
are super important.
What is the fact or
piece of information
that the audience is really
going to remember the most
or surprise them?
In the Smarter Every Day
video about the cat flipping,
it's just that whole
concept of a cat
can seemingly defy
the laws of gravity,
but it's really just a
modification of their torque
or something that
actually makes them
able to flip the way to do.
And the biggest one is what
is the point of this video?
Now, the guys who wrote
the viral video manifesto,
they used to be circus
performers, so in their book
they talk about how there's a
slideshow circus pitch, which
is when you have the
ringleader around the side
and he's like step right
up, step right up, come
see the world's smallest person
next to the world's giant man
or something like that, right?
There should be some
sort of circus sideshow
pitch to your video idea.
So one of the
episodes we made was
on farts, which
maybe our motivation
was just that we wanted to
make a video about farts.
But on the other hand, there's
this amazing biochemical
process that's associated
with all of that,
and it really reflects just
this incredible diversity
of microbiomes that
exist in your body.
And so it's not just step
right up, step right up,
come watch a video about farts.
It's like step right
up, step right up--
what's the thing I wrote?
Witness your body's countless
armies of lowly bacteria
squeeze every drop of
energy from your gut
and create horrendous
sounds and smells.
So there should be some
sort of circus sideshow
pitch to your
video, and Chris is
going to help us realize
that in the actual way of how
do I actually make that
video, how do I actually
create that vision.
So that's what we're going to
do for the last part of class.
But be thinking about maybe
what your circus sideshow
pitch is going to be.
And eventually
tonight everyone is
going to need to create
a very short, maybe
two-minute video, one
to two-minute video,
a science, technology,
engineering,
math topic that
you're basically going
to pitch through this video.
It's going to be sort of a
trailer for your final project.
All right, Chris, I
will let you take over.